[Music]
the first is after the sabbath seal is
there another seal no
that's right and then
that's it okay and now when you say
let me explain the same scene let me
comment on it
uh the sound of seal is really
you see god has
there's an invisible seal and there's a
visible seal what do i mean by that
when you totally surrender the life to
god that's internal you make a decision
it happens on here no one sees them
how am i to know you are totally
surrendered to god
the willingness to keep the sabbath
despite the death penalty
now this the outward expression of an
internal condition are you following me
in the days of abraham they had a sign
it was circumcision but you couldn't
tell abraham was circumcised i mean the
man was fully clothed or any of the
other men you could not tell so that was
hidden but the outward life of strict
obedience to god's law genesis 26 verse
5 abraham kept my commandments my charge
my statutes my laws so the outward lie
is the representation of the fact that
in me i have made up my mind and i can
see that or people can see that by my
external behavior faith must have works
and so keeping up the sabbath is the
external evidence that inwardly i am
settled let me use the word settled in
the truth and nothing will move me you
want to kill me kill me i'm keeping
god's self
so you can so the seal is on the inside
but it has an external expression
which is unflinching obedience
amen amen
thank you all the skeet and by virtue
you have answered the other question was
which was is there a sabbath seal
yes there is a sabbath seal
you